what's going on dr. Ian hello dr. Smith
what's up guys how are you good I'm just
finishing my eggs real quick you look
like you look like evil dr. Ian Smith
though because you never go to you last
time oh yeah I changed up a little bit
yeah okay I know I don't mind it I had
it you know most about 15 books I
figured dude like things a little
different on tortoise this year I like
it you look like Stone Cold Steve Austin
hey I know uh a friend of yours from
college you do Mina really so I'm in
Philly yeah and that's my girl I was
gonna her show and I'm talking I'm
talking was like yeah you don't go up to
New York I'm gonna do Jim and Sam she
goes Sam I was like yeah Sam she goes I
know him and she pulls up a picture of
you oh really
I don't like that Sam like what yeah we
went to we did radio together in
Syracuse for a while when we were when
the college station uh-huh and she does
she hosts she's doing really really well
she's a morning show in Philly now power
99 she's hard and she'd uh probably
gonna get a gig with the Sixers doing
like an in-game hole oh really
yeah always have to show you wrong I was
on her radio show yeah yeah and T we
just got the talk and I didn't know all
this time that you she's like my girl
girl you know really funny yeah that's
real cool yeah I said I'm gonna tell him
when I get to New York
the minute yeah doing what yeah she's
doing well that's awesome
what's up guys I'm good how are you man
you just determined to stay in shape huh
I'm trying I put a little bit on you
know how it is I'm a little bit yeah
point two you should see him dr. Ian I
mean Jim is a very discipline because he
knows I've watched him and when he gets
off the train he gets off the train like
it was we go
example off the train so we did it we
were doing a podcast over at Bert
Chrysler's house and this was a while
back this was like after Halloween or
something huh and Bert had a jar of
those like fun-sized candy bars from
trick-or-treat yeah and I watched him
and his compulsion and he was like okay
normally I wouldn't have any zero is
what my role is but I'll have one and I
sat there watching this monster shovel
Snickers bars wholesome out hey just one
hand or the other I said he couldn't
possibly be this hungry
he's just composed just a greedy for him
you wanna do that when you go and you go
home it was amazing to watch because he
says like oh I can't stop and I'm like
ah whatever you're just saying that then
I watched him and I went no he really
it's until the [ __ ] bag is empty
that's when you stop I was I was licked
my finger and get the salt yeah but is
this inability to do it just being a
greedy slide see yes that's why I try
not to do it well you look you look you
know we start you start this journey a
long time ago thank you thanks to you I
did because you were the one that got me
started eating healthy to begin with
because I was I was an anchor in like
2007 or whatever when you started when
every year you started coming around we
were at Cairo and I was like I got to do
something I was [ __ ] up and I was all
out of shape and you don't wanna cut me
round the road you weren't eating well
you know you know not all all right I
mean because it must be frustrating when
you watch people they're like yeah I'm
gonna make it change I'm gonna take your
advice and they do it for a week and
they just like fall off the wagon how
for for one success like Jim you see him
stay stay on this thing how many
failures does that make up for like in
your head or does it not even well it's
like golf right so in golf people play
golf you know when you get that one
great hole where everything is connected
you know this is so beautiful
you will take a hundred bad holes of
golf for that one that's like dating so
you know someone like Jim who is like a
complete success store you know
everyone's not gonna in nutrition
everything else but yeah you know it's
one of those things where it's a life
journey you know I'm saying and you know
a lot of people who listen to the show
have done well they keep in touch with
me they're on my social media and now
they show me you know before and afters
I heard you on you know Jim and Sam and
blah blah so you know it's been it's
like inspirational for me and I meet
people you know like out and about and
they're like hey I listen to you and in
fact you know one of my um my former
assistant in Chicago
husband loves you guys and his name is
dan Plante so I'm gonna say what's up to
Dan I'm sure he's gonna listen now or
listen to you know to the replay but but
yeah so people just you know they listen
to you guys they do well and it excites
me and you know I just keep motoring
along yeah you keep putting out books I
got lazy I can't write I write and I
stop and I write I stop your ability
just to [ __ ] keep pumping out books
is amazing I admire you really just sit
down and do it here's my analogy LeBron
James dunks the basketball I write books
I mean this is what I do is write you
know and I you know they're like so many
I have like 15 ideas in my head and I
just don't have time to write them like
I tell my editor yesterday I was like
cheese I want to do this one this one
this one listen so yeah but clean 20 is
a book that actually they actually
rejected the book why because at this
point why are they rejecting why there
are no more bestsellers but you keep
pumping out good books like every time
another one comes out you do the
promotion for it everybody buys the book
you're like just trust me at this point
right or her word you ready she said and
her Yalie erudite voice surely she said
it's so derivative and I was like
derivative what are you talking about
like this is a clean eating book for
people who want to do it who can't
afford expensive food who want an easy
plan this is for the everyday person
this isn't for someone who like lives on
Park Avenue you know on the Upper East
Side and so I was like it's not
derivative I said and by the way every
idea I come up with is not gonna be like
the greatest thing in the world like you
know people you'll do things that are
have been talked about before but
they're favors like what do you expect
you're putting food in your mouth and we
all know where it comes out how many
different ways are there to do that geez
so I said to her so she so she says I
don't know let me think about it so I
went there boss that's it I said her
boss listen I have this great idea for a
book that's called the clean 2020 foods
20 days total transformation I have a
thousand people on Facebook who I've
been doing it with and they're losing
crazy weight like the average weight
loss in 20 days is 10 pounds she was
like when we gonna do it I was like
you're not gonna do it she was why I
said because they Lizbeth said no and
she was whoa give me a second so two
days later I get a call from her she
says I'm so excited we're doing good but
anyway um I love her she's not like my
work right
so we've been together for 10 years but
anyway I did this book because people
hear the words clean eating and they
think that you know you got to buy
rabbit food and all this gourmet crap
it's not true clean eating simply means
taking away and you've done allow this
in your own work taking away a lot of
the processed food so you look at the
back of a label of you know Twinkies or
whatever and you'll see they're like 20
ingredients and half the names you can't
pronounce right and and those all those
processes they last forever that's why
they last forever right that's right
because they also use the same
ingredient in turpentine
so uh anyway I wanted to write a book
that was really accessible that was easy
you could be a vegan a vegetarian a
carnivore or Pescatore doesn't matter
you can do the plan and it's
customizable so in this book and by the
way people say this is my easiest plan
that everyone who says this is the
easiest thing ever it's just twenty days
everything spelled out for you you can
mix and match and substitute but you
make your own clean twenty list yeah
it's hard to find clean like I like
snack bars I eat these are X bars
because they're kind of clean uh-huh and
then the stuff that's in them isn't that
bad but a quest bars like [ __ ] candy
bars well how do you know
I mean tasty there you always hear about
like you know if you're gonna just go to
the supermarket and you're trying to get
regular food but it's like well there's
hormones and all the chicken and there's
chemicals and the meat and there's I
like hormones in check I want my chicken
have nice big tits and pesticides on the
fruit yeah you know what let's take to
those things let's start with the
pesticides first of all pesticides don't
matter unless you're eating the skin so
it's called right so if you you don't
need an organic banana you're peeling
the skin it's the pesticide residue
that's on the skin that people are
worried about you know heal that Apple
your pill well if you're if you're not
gonna have an organic apple then you
peel the Apple right I see but this is
the truth of the matter most 99 $7.99
percent of people will never have a
problem from pesticide residue it just
it's one of those theoretical things
that yeah if you ate like a bushel of
something and I had you know point
something percent of the pesticide it
just doesn't happen it sounds scary it
sounds scary but in this in this book I
talked about going organic because of
the processing so for example you can
have turkey you can have chicken you can
have pasta it's a lot of food in this
book but I do say make sure there's no
and about
takes no hormones and you can get that
pretty easily you know will say
hormone-free antibiotic-free so i do
advise for these 20 days do you do that
so it's cleaner that's right but it says
it right there on it says on the lab
salutely what's a basket buddy birthday
well I'm not gonna go there
don't ask Travis so this is how you make
the thing work for you so a basket buddy
is I make a suggestion and you don't
like my suggestion and so you have all
these other possibilities that you can
use oh okay right so it's on page 16 is
the list and so basically this is how
you can customize the plan so let's see
here make you me examples like tomatoes
okay great are you crazy
to me I love Tomatoes there's cheese on
it listen for example let's say you know
you don't like almonds you can have
sunflower seeds pumpkin seeds chia seeds
hemp seeds flax seeds let's say you
don't like kale you can have brussel
sprouts cabbage so you can kind of mix
and match the way you like and so that
was that's why people say it's so easy
because it's customizable so you're also
in there's you know past five days a
week to you know you're not just looking
healthy cuz you're just eating healthy
so I'm glad you said that I do work out
a lot I'd like to work out but in the
book it's only 20 minutes of workout so
every day and you don't work out every
day but the days that you have exercise
I give you just 20 minutes you can do
without a gym you can do it in your
house you can do it here in the studio
so it's 20 minutes that's all you do and
I give you these exercises to do and let
me tell you something I have people who
are like 75 years old people were 400
pounds 120 pounds who are doing it and
it works for everyone based on what
they're trying to do and if speaking of
which you know like to give stuff away
sure yeah you do yeah we got a whole box
of shred pops been going through in the
office last week we loved it so listen
if you want to do the clean 20 program
join my facebook group it's called the
clean 20 the numerals to zero and if
you're gonna pick up a copy of the book
I will send you a free workout DVD it's
a twenty seven minute workout you
workout with me I'll give you a download
link so you can do it right to your
device and it's easy so hit me up email
me the clean 22 zero at gmail.com if you
want to do the plan and unfit on
Instagram it's at dr. Ian Smith spell
the doctor you reset every like two
years you have a whole new thing alright
[ __ ] you the Facebook thing is this you
hit me up with this you'll get that like
you
you're like a corporation no I'm a
one-man band but the idea is because
like my other book I like to separate
people so some people are doing shred
some are doing blasters sugar out you
know to lower your blood Sugar's and so
people want to eat clean we have a whole
clean twenty challenge like 6,000 people
doing it so far was it scary at all when
when Celebrity Fit Club went away
because obviously Celebrity Fit Club is
gonna make it a whole lot easier for you
to get your face out there and get books
out there and everything when that show
goes away and it's like okay now it's
just on you to be this guy you know I
mean you know I never thought about it
like that
because I you know I do like the morning
shows Good Morning America or Today Show
CNN so I never really felt like I
wouldn't be able to get my word out but
I will say this now with social media
the way it is like the dependence that
we used to have on like these major
channels to put us on you know thank
goodness with social media because you
know banging a producer to come on in a
Booker you Booker won't return your
publicist o'clock you know so now you
can I go directly to Instagram or
Twitter Facebook you know I got you know
Korra's million people were on Facebook
with me so actually now you can just
kind of do your thing and people like it
you can direct the people you have to
beg producers to get on did you ever
have that period we're like nobody wants
to have you on well know everyone been
you know knocking what people always
been really good to me but what would
happen is the shows are very territorial
like they would say if you do his show
you can't do my show if you do that show
so it became like a fire drill like so
then you had to decide who are you gonna
do I won't mention names of shows but
and then I would say to my publicist who
cares the people who watch this show do
not watch that show one show has
strippers on it the other show has nuns
on it they're not they're two different
are you talking about our battle with
the Catholic Channel because we still
are holding strong if you do watch a you
can't to us yeah no Catholic Channel
guess we'll do our share we tell our
celebrity friends if you do stern you
cannot do this show and when they say
[ __ ] you Eagle could you please do us
after you do this way you don't do us
well I'm doing well how about stopping
by and by hey I'm doing you guys before
sway that was obviously his choice Jim
how long we've been together many years
many many years know I always say listen
I'm gonna start doing series I got it
going on Jim and Sam it was
you know Oh pshh oh but you know I do
you guys you guys are my guys and
speaking of that like you know you're
talking about getting frustrated with
people that don't follow up the first
thought that occurred to me when we got
that giant box of popcorn to the office
we were all eating it was years ago when
you came in here and this whole thing
was set up and you're gonna have a rock
and roll in lose weight and they were
gonna compete with each other to
motivate each other there's gonna be
this whole thing and you came in
expecting a transformation and when you
walked in both of them looked exactly
the same and both of them said well I
think I think II Rock said you didn't
send me a blender and Roman said you
didn't send me popcorn in the history of
my parents in the show I got a laugh now
these guys went after me and I'm like it
was like vitriol I'm like are you crazy
like you don't abandon mom I got a free
blender he really took it personally
going acting like dude I'm like I'm just
trying to help you out like hold on for
a second and then um and so the people
online they were like you know you
screwed a rock you know you're this year
they're as I only count talking to God
so uh you know I learned my lesson I
don't mess with a rocker rollin anymore
you know I pray for them I saw rollin
yesterday rolling you looks big he
lookin he lost weight right he
definitely Saul he looks like he looks
great I guess somebody must have sent
him a blender there no well you know I
did I set them blender I know you daft
er that I unloaded the frickin warehouse
and I was like I'm not gonna come in the
studio with the trolls online like going
off with dr. Ian you didn't live up to
you were blah blah blah so you know you
rock he's down to 135 what on coke Jim I
don't know where's true I haven't seen
no you know he stays now he looks he's
about the same busy I hope not I'm gonna
see em for dinner you are for real yeah
we've got yeah hey Rock GC wants you to
pay for everything
give me a blender send me pop yeah
exactly exactly but now we had some good
times with those guys it was fun
Karen has a question for you yes Karen
you're on the phone hi my question is
for dr. is
my husband has a last-minute as cancer
and he needs to lower his his sugar
levels and things like that do you have
a book that would kind of help him
because we've been it's kind of hard he
loves pasta
well hey Karen first of all nice is one
of the 20 foods was the one the 20 the
clean twenty book will work for him and
let me tell you why because it actually
does not totally eliminate sugar but it
reduces your carbohydrates to good carbs
and the reason just so people know that
when you have cancer sugar feeds cancer
cells so you really yeah they eat sort
of meat doesn't meet feed cancer no I'm
a red meat well red meat may stimulate
they think you know nitrites may may
stimulate cancer growth but for someone
who has an actual cancer sugar is like
fuel for the cancer cells for the growth
and so people the advice is to lower
your cancer your lower your cigarette
intake so if he filed a clean 20 there
is no added sugars which is what you
need to stay away from there are natural
sugars and like fruits and vegetables
those are natural sugars but it would
not be a problem so he should definitely
do it it's easy it's lots of food
because he does need his calories when
you you know when you have cancer you
need calories so yeah so definitely
check it out and join our Facebook group
the clean 20 the number is 2-0 at the
end okay also one more quick thing yeah
have you ever heard of Essiac t spelling
because you think it's called essiac t
es si si no but what real quick what
what is it well it's supposed to kind of
it didn't it's an American Indian kind
of T that are supposed to fight cancer
and things like that we've been doing it
for a while and tests have been coming
back pretty well scrt okay yeah it's
probably high in antioxidants that's
probably I haven't heard this particular
T but it's probably high in antioxidants
antioxidants are disease fighters they
fight free radicals and so if it's
herbal and it's natural I don't see a
problem with it
just make sure there aren't a lot of
kind of additives in it that's all
no it's additive free Afeni oh yeah
that's good that's good thank you so I'm
sorry about that so obviously you know
you take about processed food fast foods
bad
but what's your take on subway what's
your take on chip Oatley if I had to
choose between the two let's start that
way okay I would choose to potently okay
all day long
so is it like processed uh cuz it seems
like the G stuff is just sitting there
right processed the [ __ ] meats in a
box in the back you talk about nitrates
and stuff I mean I don't want to like go
in on subway sure but but I do not never
have I never even as a kid when I was
not even a health person I just didn't
like the idea like Jim said that but the
meat was just kind of sitting around and
you know so I never ate subway but then
you know all these stories about their
bread a mattress there or yeah Jim Matt
stuff is in the bread you hear yeah the
fillers that they were used and once
again I'm not trying to get into a
lawsuit with Subway right I'm just
saying what was reported you know
fillers that they use in their meats and
all this kind of all this because on one
end Jared Fogle lost all that weight but
then I also worry that if the sandwiches
contributed to the other stuff I don't
know I don't know that you've only
recently after his trouble that's when
Sam began supporting someone but are you
okay that guy try to go like to like the
president Trump or to the way I'd like
to get out early this case stands for
Trump to take crossing state lines for
underage sex yeah that's tough it's
tougher for the president to publicly
stick up for you come on but I don't
know well listen is it I don't think
it's tough for him you think you might
be able to file it anyway if anybody had
let's not go there
I want the guys hate not mean something
oh yeah that's no matter what side you
take there will have but you like what's
your feelings on Chipotle would you eat
it remotely yeah yeah my wife my family
is the Chipotle okay I mean if we're in
a rush listen you can't always sit at
home and you know cook whole gourmet
food are you married yeah you know that
I didn't remember that friend what's a
good food for memory radio but it is I
do want to know green tea green tea
hurts my stomach oh it's empty
it does yeah some ginkgo biloba you ever
have a ginkgo biloba you know what I've
heard helps with memory is not sitting
in front of a laptop for hours on end
masturbating right now I really I'm on
pause on home you can't be good that's
all this is a three-hour part of my
family James in LA has a question hey
what's up guys I had a question about
the organic burst Jia motivate I know
you're talking about organic do two
pesticides but are you do you recommend
organic versus conventional for like
other other health benefits to that or
is it just you recommending against the
pesticides and then aren't there also
herbicides in organic food that can be
just as harmful as in you know
traditional yeah yeah this is a great
question so first of all you know I you
know I believe in organic I don't
believe everything should be needs to be
organic by the way I think that the
organic hype is really kind of a little
to the extreme you think about you know
traditional farming and people have been
eating that way for many years and
didn't develop all these different
diseases I think the danger now is that
a big agricultural companies are
manipulating the food chain genetically
modifying things putting all the types
of chemicals and since that synthetic
increases it that we didn't have before
and so you know for me personally you
know I have like I drink organic milk I
don't want cows that have been pumped
with hormones and antibiotics but as far
as fruits and vegetables produce you
know I stick only to organic when I'm
eating the skin but I think that you
know people should make decisions not
based on the hype but based on what
makes sense you know everything does not
need to be organic but if you're eating
if you're in by the way it's like your
fish for example I would say when I go
to restaurant has a wild car I don't
want fish that's been raised in a pen
and then eating each other's crap you
know for you know weeks and that's how
you get mercury poisoning so you know
I'm just going
but I'm not perfect so you've been
eating German fish thank you James you
mentioned the organic milk this is a
question I have I get the my wife gets
the milk in the red card and I don't
remember what the brand name is but it
says something I know Hormel that might
know horizon probably it says organic
it's organic milk yep
but the expiration date is isolation way
longer than like regular milk does at
the store that you the boxes they use
the inside of the box I'm just telling
you the inside of the milk carton is it
is it really does it's the I mean that's
for like a month
what a no like a week no supermarket
milk will like a week week and a half
this stuff lasts for like a month so I
said no and like is there stuff in it no
keeping it typically actually organic
typically lasts less because Janek
doesn't have that's what I thought yeah
but then the the red cart and stuff that
says somebody listen to is can someone
check this out and see 7 to 10 days
yeah oh you got a refrigerate it that
point yeah no it typically typically
organic will not organic foods tend not
to last as long a rap as traditionally
yeah but with the milk I don't know
maybe it's that is it pasteurized see
maybe it's not pasteurized it's gotta be
so if it's if it's unpasteurized it
won't last as long - hmm
right if you don't if it doesn't go to
the pasteurization process but Sam's
saying his milk lasts for a month and
it's supposed to be organic it says
organic but maybe it's pasture I drink
that milk by the way yeah you know yeah
last last three to four weeks you know I
mean my isn't sit that long my my kids
freaking pretty pretty fast but it never
lasts but I don't know it's pretty cool
yeah interesting all right bill in
Pennsylvania hey Bill hey I'm a truck
driver and I guess went to the doctors
and stuff he says my blood is too thick
I don't drink enough water stuff so I'm
back to drink the water but I want to
lose weight I got a trucker gut that's
your own thing it's badass I just don't
know how to eat right or whatever so how
much do you weigh yeah what is the
trucker's got that means there's hookers
fingernails in it
now I was six foot four and they weigh
235 that's not bad that's not bad yeah
dudes like you weighed 350 you're sick
you're 64 wait so you're just worried
about your midsection right yeah my I
know I can't stand it yeah well let me
just say this we just had a guy actually
who just posted me on the Facebook page
he's about 63 like 320 and lost like 30
pounds already let me say that you know
unfortunately when you lose weight you
can't do what's called spot reduction
which is terms like I want to lose fat
in the back of my arms I'm gonna lose
fat around my happens so you have what's
called generalized weight loss but for
someone like you I probably would bet
since you're a truck driver and you
probably eat a lot of truck stops
correct restaurant yeah yes yeah but I
try to stay away from the greasy stuff
okay only lately last month or so I've
been eating salads and stuff like that
or but we're you know but what you
probably need to see the problem I'd
love this kind of question you are
eating probably half decent but you
don't have a plan you need to
specifically follow like this is what
I'm doing day 1 day 2 day 3 so I think
you'd be ideal for the clean 20 and yeah
are you working out at all at all that's
what I'd about I'm always on the go I
don't have time Melissa on the weekend
but you know what to do what have you
pulled the truck over and just run laps
around it that's I mean that's that
wouldn't look weird at all no not at all
right of the highway running laps around
your dodge run in and out of everyone
else's truck park making the wee noise
in all seriousness you could get out of
your truck and do 10 minutes of exercise
like my book only says 20 minutes so
just 10 minutes maybe you maybe you
exercise you can find what I would
recommend is find two other truck
drivers that are friends with you and
start like double dutch League why not
and maybe like if you driver double
dutch like yeah yeah a lot lizard let me
give an example if you were gonna let me
give you example steam engines for
example or in the book so steam engine
is where you put opposite knee to
opposite elbow it's like a standard
crunch they do it a lot in the military
that's one ice-skaters you can do this
is all next to your truck you can do ice
skaters you can do
high knees you can do jock punches in
the back of the book I actually show you
and demonstrate these exercises for you
you don't need a gym you could do this
I'm it's no joke there's pictures yeah I
show you how to do all these different
all these different moves okay like us I
I grab a huge sleeper bigger than
average
I got a queen-size bed I got a small
kitchen
you got a queen-size bed in your trunk
and a kitchen yeah I want to see
pictures of them obsessed with big with
big I almost a big rigs but I realize
that's a bad way to phrase those giant
those giant tractors yeah I almost came
to one of your concerts I couldn't get
back in time and I was crazy affected
the meet and greet and show you the
truck oh man does your queen-size bed
does it fold out or is it always out no
it's always out we got a queen-size bed
in your [ __ ] way dude right let's
show you the bed yeah not the greatest
advice you could find you drive mostly
in the Midwest no I Drive all over
United States Wow with a truck that size
Mike I would love to see that bill as
you've driven around the United States
have you noticed the testa fication
process going across the US of A okay so
bill is known as the US of A is getting
testified in that great track yeah
there's a lot I tooked a lot of guys on
to your show let's go to the truck stop
I'll have a blast when I'm cleaning my
windows and stuff like that and it guys
a kebab goes who the hell are these guys
Jim thank you Danny Bramson start it all
over yeah it doesn't mean anytime before
we let you go now I know you're clay
about diet stuff more truck questions oh
my god I have to ask how many miles to a
gallon do you get in that drug what are
you doing I'm curious about seven and a
half that's and how many gallons is your
tank what the load I get over about
three 375 400 down I'm fascinated by
these guys you're driving a small house
around I want to go to sit in that truck
and just be a boy like to take give me
on a run like going to one of the shows
you stick
a trip goes to show a lone senator I
maybe Club it and maybe put him in a
parking lot and try to drive it no like
that my dad took me in his truck once I
would be funny if you just took me to a
parking lot and taught me how to drive
your truck thank you very much bill we
appreciate it
they sent me an email the clean twenty20
the clean twenty at gmail.com and I'll
get you a free copy of the DVD so you
can work out this is your truck okay all
right give me some pictures which are
close on at least the covers on a
king-size bed that's a queen bed and the
boss is gonna blow your mind awesome
they make entire homes inside of houses
inside a car no more nerds motorhomes
that is that glad a cab of a truck gonna
start the trek the tractor area of a
tractor trailer I mean it's [ __ ] your
monstrous their monstrous yeah they
would be bigger to fit the kitchen in
the bed dude that's amazing mobile home
is one thing but you're not pulling you
know [ __ ] a trailer behind a mobile
home hey doctor in hey what's up man not
much man yeah quit smoking near 35 days
ago congratulations that's doing like I
gained about 30 pounds in certain how
many days
that's gonna be my book gained 30 pounds
in 30 days with the Sam Roberts died no
no are you serious about these numbers
and 35 days you gained 30 pounds
okay well listen okay yeah I'll let you
go and finish a question kind of sounds
like is having a heart attack right now
as he stinks yeah it's not good like I'm
a truck driver to try to get out to do
some work but I'm just wondering if that
book will help me out and drop me down
to like 200 how much you weigh in
230 250 yeah I mean for sure I mean it's
I mean are you on are you on social
media at all oh okay
so first of all join our Facebook group
okay cuz you can talk to me live I've
added my facebook live sessions you can
ask me questions but yeah the book will
help you
it's called the clean twenty you can get
it on your device so you can the road
you I mean you you can get on your cell
phone if you want you can download it or
you can get a hard copy and take with
you but yeah I'll help you but listen
dude let me just say this I rather you
get rid of the smokes first and have the
weight and then attack the weight
because there's nothing worse than smoke
sometime but is the smoking good to lose
the weight like should you start smoking
again and then lose the weight not a bad
idea
well no no maybe
oh Jesus I can tell you through my
experience I quit smokey and I fattened
up after I quit smoking it's quitting
smoking is the best thing I ever did
right the only thing Jim smokes now is
pole well I don't smoke it I'll just
hold an admirer but I I quit that was
the best thing I ever made put the
weight on and you'll lose the weight but
not smoking is the best thing I've done
yeah as an adult I'm telling you listen
I'm telling you I'm telling you if you
follow this book for twenty days you
will lose at least 10 pounds you
particularly you will lose at least
twenty ten pounds in this book I'm
telling you I guarantee you and if you
don't lose it I'll give you a seven the
book back to me I'll give you money I
don't care dr. Ian says if you don't
lose the weight he'll eat his hat that's
right give you his fortune what's up
buddy yes I seen you down in Salt Lake
when you're down there on a Saturday
night man excellent oh thanks man yeah I
love that gig I was on my way back from
Vancouver I did some yeah I did just
toot one night they let you into Utah I
do surprisingly well in Utah I think I'm
a breath of fresh air
I'm the scent of garbage wafting the
ministry we've never seen this before
thank you very much all right are you
performing this weekend Jim yeah I'm
working in the Poconos we're in the
Poconos Joe's nightclub I think it's
called where's that the Polka teams take
take number where where can people find
it Roscoe's because there's so many
spots in the Poconos it's so beautiful I
wanted me to sing it take me take me
through take me through tonight on like
this like what so what happens you get
on the bus you plant well how do you
like you go there you're there
good night before the same day take me
through depending on where it is like
Mount Airy Lodge I'll drive to where
Mount Airy Lodge Poconos and I'll get
there and I'll do my ritual of standing
in front of the mirror and I do my
entire act and after every joke I clap
and I go but instead of my dick I take
my notebook outside no I I just get more
impressive it really is very very boring
ritual I just I walk in right before I
go onstage the opening act is on five
minutes before I go on I hear the
closing bit I start to pee I walk
onstage I do my hour I'm out it's just
an hour
it's an hour yes how am I suppose so you
drive by yourself you get a team well
huh no no no team I sometimes I bring
Kenny with me but Kenny's been doing his
own private security stuff which pays
them more yeah it depends on where I'm
going when I'm doing coming up by God's
Fort Lauderdale in Orlando back to back
so I'll fly in day before do some
morning radio you're by yourself
sometimes sometimes no it depends on
what Kenny is available yeah I'm with my
opener okay and I'll do the gig in
Orlando and then I'll usually it's by a
three-hour drive to the next city I hate
flying in between cities uh-huh I'll
Drive three three and a half hours one
night check into the hotel
sleep wake up do the gig Sunday morning
at home Monday morning I'm back here and
do you already have sorry am I allowed
to ask you do you already have kind of
like how your shows gonna lay out or is
it a lot of it spontaneous like how does
it work you know what you're gonna do
you have like your hour are your
material and then you kind of go
off-book a little bit and get the people
in the crowd but normally you know what
you're gonna do is sure oh yeah what you
work that people don't want to see you
working out material if they're paying
fifty dollars or thirty dollars
particularly right the hour set is not
the time to work out no not at all you
do a new joke or something or a new
couple of minutes but it's not the time
to go up there and do a new 15 and do
you like interact afterward or you just
get out of there I used to sell stuff
afterwards but the venue started
complaining because the lines were long
and they want to get out of there and
they just started getting but we got a
complaint at the complaint so sometimes
I'll do meet-and-greets before okay
right after because those are contained
and you know exactly how many people
it's gonna be right and you do you
usually end with your character work
sometimes I do yeah I'll do chip at the
end if they demand if I got to start
bringing the waiting glasses I can't do
without that you just cease the crowd
depends on the room sometimes a thousand
people sometimes I don't say well
it's 400 people and sometimes not well
is 400 people that it depends on the
size of the room if it's a comedy club
that's great it's a 1200 seat theater I
should be killed depends on the size of
the place 100 people is a lot of tickets
not really not in a big venue it's not
it's not it depends on where you where
you're working and and one more question
do you have to is there always an open
or do you something yeah I don't like
going out cold
I like having somebody go up front
Liana's a little bit yeah and just kind
of get the audience CD people are out
buying drinks and they come in and it
has to be a comedian who opens up for
you
I prefer that yeah yeah some guys want
music acts I prefer a come on never
tried juggler
no I would though if it entertained the
people yeah you know people like juggle
you want a comedian who's different than
you that's all yeah that's why usually
women oh because I want someone who's
not the same vibe his name yeah and
they're not going to attack things the
same way yeah you really show comics
unleashed
I've Byron Allen is a he's he's really a
genius as far as what he's dumb and I've
never done that she bought The Weather
Channel
yeah he's brilliant yeah just but I
don't want to do it because you're
giving away a piece your act for very
very low money no so I just never do
they offered me a few times they don't
fly you out and we know we said no
thanks I mean whatever they they're good
for comedians you know look he provides
a lot of comics with a gig yeah
phenomenal like stuff some of them when
I'm up late working and I'm watching CBS
that show will come on that was like
Jesus where hasn't Jim on the show you
know why the it was what it was
it's just comics unleash it was that
you're doing material tough crap people
use just kind of like to sit there and
we were right for that episode and then
but comics at least you're doing your
act and I guess Byron's job is just to
kind of throw to you yeah he does he'll
say stuff like so I just think you
bought a fish tank and you'd be like
what is it with fish tank ship I am and
they break you know these guys ten
minutes on fish tanks Andy Kindler had a
very funny joke these cities we called
comics uncomfortable because that's
exactly what it is people uncomfortably
segue into the rap yeah
alright we while we have the good doctor
here we have a couple weird I think
food-related medical ailments on staff
oh my god we do yes did I feel like you
could help with who do you want to start
with um whoever you want I mean we could
bring one in at a time we could bring
them both in I mean and just kind of see
which works what do you think yeah we'll
bring in Anthony first okay and I can be
honest here yeah please like be honest
you may be able to help yeah
and by the way Lilia beef while he's
coming out I don't know this is true
chip in Tennessee going on a truck a
normal truck sleeper truck is roughly
around 70 feet long 8 feet wide and if
you walk around it 20 times that's
supposed to equal 1 mile Wow I turn you
off turn doctor I read to turn off
number 2 sorry what well yeah Sam just
said that
I mean Sam said to him you know just run
around your truck I mean you're
absolutely right absolutely right and
Sam wasn't trying to be helpful
I'm a fitness expert we have to take a
30-minute break sometime within the
first eight hours of our shift that half
hour break yeah get out walk around your
truck that's a tough life too you do a
mile I go to truck stop sometimes on the
way to a gig and you see like they have
the bathrooms in the little these little
rooms they watch TV
that's a [ __ ] that's a really lonely
life man being a trucker chip they
chipped my favorite can you post what
you just said in our group would you do
that which one post your comment in our
facebook facebook group are you dr. Ian
let's called the clean twenty20 the
clean twenty because it's different if
another truck driver says it two versus
my saying if you say it's much different
the clean twenty we got a guy named
Kevin Schneider in that group was a
truck driver out in Indiana all right
already
all right chip thanks man thought so
okay here we go
Anthony has an issue he hasn't figured I
mean there's a kind of a clear solution
to it but he just can't stick to 85
years old so but he does live at home
with mom so like yes we just always
stocked like there's temptation there
mm-hmm
and apparently he he throws up he spends
the morning throwing up if he eats
anything after what time nine o'clock
[Laughter]
and he continuously eats after nine
o'clock and continuously comes into work
queasy yeah he's a fly true or false
true and you throw up a lot not a lot
just like if I eat like something like
like what kind of stuff yeah like if I
eat like like a lot of cheez-its I do
love cheese's doing square yeah there's
no better snack than [ __ ] box of
cheez-its I can eat like a bot I can
literally do box of cheese they rule you
ever have an ice cream [ __ ] dippin
rule that vanilla ice in vanilla ice
cream and scoop it it sounds a little
treat for yourself sweet and salty
combination I got one question for you
how how long after you eat do you go to
bed what's the interval like about 15-20
minutes 9:30 right sometimes 9:30 9:45
they also you should know and I think
this is part of it he smokes copious
amounts of marijuana so that's it's hard
for me to legal now it's hard for me to
not have Munchie food at that time
because that's all I want like kettle
chips you could not you could not two
things well first of all these first of
all you're going first of all you're
going to sleep to close after you eat
that's a mistake a lot people make so
you got a 15 minutes is not an I'm gonna
say like an hour okay well no it should
be 90 minutes but your 15 minutes so
your food yeah your food is frickin
refluxing back up your esophagus first
of all just falls asleep with crumbs I'm
eating doodads and drinking old granddad
and secondly you gotta make sure you
don't have what's called a hiatal hernia
which means that your stomach is
abnormally protruding up into your
thorax your chest cavity has that
directs doing yeah it's not good not the
lorax but the thorax how do you fix the
hiatal hernia unfortunately sometimes
it's okay if you don't fix it but
sometimes you need surgical intervention
I think that might be what you need that
make you nauseous a lot yeah that effect
directions
[Laughter]
but now seriously you need to first of
all stop you should not go to sleep
within 90 minutes of eating first of all
that's tough because you get here's what
happens with him
smokes copious amounts of marijuana then
he gets hungry then he gets sleepy true
or false true yeah finish you 28 huh
you do no exercise do you I wrestled for
like 15 years so my body
normal wrestle yes my body is just and
you look like this now yeah yes well you
can't tell cuz he's wearing that kind of
jacket
let me see without the jack are you in
shape I mean um no strip-down
skinny fat skinny fat yes fat tell ya
these fat I wouldn't say he's tremendous
he's not that bad he's baggy clothes
he's got no muscle tone skinny fat zero
no never I never had muscle tone even as
a wrestler you know cuz I had to cut a
lot of weight so like I couldn't put
like lift as much as I could that's a
cool no offense
you gotta start working out man you're
28 yeah you got to start working out I
mean I hate doing it and what do you
write five five five six five seven five
six yeah you got to work out man I mean
you're you're soft how about you wait
last time I checked I was like 152
pounds the last time you checked was a
while back huh there's the puck the way
it's not your problem by the way it's
it's not the way is that you're just you
got to get tightened flappy yeah see
that's a good word frumpy yeah yeah I'm
a frumpy man man yeah that much from pon
your honor said I think you're fast just
tight just tone up a light tone up it's
just soft like do you know you have you
ever lifted weights
I did but I hated it I just hated it
tell me right it's power listen dude
no no but like I never liked weight yeah
no I remember I know I hated it I've
always hated doing it and every time I
used to do it I used to just my coach
would be like you you can't gain muscle
because it's heavier and you're you
cut that weight from you wouldn't do a
transformation with me if you want me to
do a transformation let's do it quick
what kind of transformation lets you and
the truck driver wants to show you
around as I can't help it people like to
cave okay so all right let's do this can
you like twenty days you do the clean
twenty but you got it no I'll do it
you gotta exercise they gotta exercise
we'll do some before and afters okay
yeah we'll post them when I come back
we'll post them under dance before and
afters you eat what kind of snacks can
you have on this diet all kinds of I
mean geez turn to this next section
there's all kind of stuff I recently
like starting starting Monday I cut out
all soda and like all that [ __ ] that's a
cheese it I just cut it all out so hard
what's your name again Anthony and okay
Anthony I call you auntie [ __ ] laughs so
you can call me I don't curse but okay
alright listen here's the deal this is
why I like this we're gonna do a
before-and-after with you alright
your father clean 20 we'll shoot the
pictures people online who filed the
show they will vote on your reveal and
if they vote that you have a nice before
and after we will gift you five hundred
dollars
why yes in Jesus Christ that's great
I'll tell you what twenty minutes to
lose that on a Monday night he's a big
gambler
you are no what do you play whatever is
on he likes to bet on whatever size yes
craps
no I never play craps I was I'm a three
card player okay and blackjack okay I
get a black jack black guys who slowly
game you know what do you play are you a
gambler no but like if I'm out with
friends or whatever like we go you know
to Vegas or something oh you know I'll
throw the dice hold on that by the way
that's not the man who put a gamble you
what would he play
why would why somebody poker in college
oh you did yeah but
we didn't have holden when I was in cut
you know to hold we didn't play Hold'em
we played all these crazy games like
baseball and 7:27 but anyway okay you
want to do it in an 20 whatever you
whatever you all right listen is that
cool so 20 days do you think it'll stop
him from throwing up in the morning
well yeah you cannot you got to follow
the book what it tells you when to eat
and stuff like that you cannot eat like
50ms we're going to sleep that's great
that might mean that you can't smoke as
much weed because nah still continue
probably you'll be able to follow those
people sooo yeah I have no problem
following the diet just I'd even you
live at home so your mom's cooking and
buying groceries
what do you do like like I'm sorry this
is so off-topic but at your age we've
enabled a girl what do you do basement
behind the boiler so she goes right to
the basement yeah geez remember those
days in high school the basement in high
school I use all the basement work I
used by is my car in the driveway I
would be in my car in the driveway when
my parents were sleep with the with the
guard up the Sun guard was it with a
girlfriend or a girl that you'd met
somewhere or music women at me you know
you where would you meet them they were
walking a streetwalker
I seen ladies of the night he's got a
shirt button down Jim's like there hey
pick up prostitutes and get the call
from that parents driveway you wouldn't
remember oh they're liberal women yeah
that women who needed some help with
money
absolutely exchange for they say they
twenty five years in advance or the back
page closer coming fast they're trying
to set some college funding money aside
we didn't you also like sneak women
downstairs into your after your
grandmother passed away into her bedroom
that is a valid point my friend and I
did do that and she did that for real
may I my grandma that had the downstairs
of the house then she passed away so why
not turn the talker day
I know you were sad I was thinking there
was a pregnant girl and she sparked up a
crack I'll never forget that she was
pregnant yeah
sewing pregnant we just knew she was
pregnant and literally eight months
pregnant and she started a crack pipe I
didn't know that my downstairs my
parents house smelling good cooking coke
I didn't know you smoked crack no she's
your grandmother dies yes she does right
all people and you go down into your
grandmother's bedroom still looks like
your grandmother's bedroom with a eight
months pregnant prostitute smoking crack
well by that point I think her bed was
out of there and it was just like a
family room sofa it wasn't that bad
exactly it was the room she had her
fatal heart attack in 1998 with
nitroglycerine honestly you are dying I
would love to have met you back on your
hand you would just have been like just
over the top like crazy like I was just
Pig I'm at a point in every alright so
we got it twenty days five hundred cash
okay don't do it - I bet he'll do help I
think you'll do it you're on social
media yeah what's your thing on social
media Instagram is a and do one one two
and okay he's tiny Anthony one ninety
[ __ ] loaf I don't know of any more guys
listen follow him on instagram follow me
at dr. Ian Smith spell the doctor out I
a in Smith and then you're gonna post
your your journey I'm gonna find out
kidding I'm gonna follow you for 20 days
yeah alright if we can get those titties
down and if you right
what no you're gonna be able to laugh at
the titties because they're gonna go
away you can oh god I'm gonna come ask
you sorry say bigger men have suffered
through it don't worry about it yes not
gonna be ashamed of yeah 20 days we'll
do the before and afters get your shots
posters before shot and then the people
at home will decide it's not my about
way this is I learn my lesson I am out
of this I am NOT gonna decide if you
want the people at home will decide
we'll take a vote and I just really hope
that our listeners don't sabotage
Anthony out of five
I will open a Twitter poll that's fair
he could use the monies I really hope
that they don't say okay that would be
unfair if he put all this hard work in
and then they just [ __ ] him out of the
money yeah yeah that would that would be
a real stinker what put it this way I'm
glad you mentioned okay so the let's say
it doesn't go very well for you as far
as the voting and survey Jim and Sam who
make the decision yeah it's more like to
override the fans oh no yeah we're here
trying off the hot seat don't get a lot
of it a lot of radio show host talk at
the fans we let the fans talk through us
that's right they just don't through us
it really this is the fan show that's
right that's why we always say we stink
okay they say what you hear right now is
white these guys are throwing in the bus
right now that's not true that's what
I'm sure I think the fans will be on
your side I do they always are as usual
they always are yeah I think so all
right good I think so
well we have a nicer younger
better-looking version of e-rock now
don't come with a gun no rock Iraq had
everything but a gun for me today I mean
he just went after me so you know let's
be cool you know peace you know ebony
and ivory right we have five minutes
left with dr. Ian yeah yeah the app and
follow you I have a question for the
doctor real quick yeah what's the
question good all day and then at night
I just I start going crazy and I can't
sleep unless I have food and so I
literally lay in bed thinking about food
till I go and I'll wake up and I'll walk
down and I'll have I'll grab two slices
of pizza two o'clock in the morning just
so I could sleep smart is this for real
yeah I know for real you're pretty good
shape considering I have to run like 5
miles every day how often melatonin that
work that helps no nobody's gonna sleep
yeah melatonin it's good some natural
melatonin
I took some last night 5 milligrams I
was up till 2:00 a.m. I'm exhausted
today
no seriously melatonin would be good
well what do I do for hunger the how do
I stop that crazy hunger you got to have
some fibers Pizza is not the option it's
fiber and protein so look for things you
know some protein bars you need stuff
that has fiber and protein in it and
it's
to eat that at two o'clock in the
morning well yeah it's a hundred fifty
calories or less absolutely and
hopefully you'll take that melatonin you
will be up at two o'clock in the morning
anymore that's the key now knee goes in
here and you'll see us I don't want to
get too much into details because I
don't want to embarrass him but yeah
they around around the office area some
of his co-workers refer to him as leaky
Nicky why that's an unfair Nick it's not
that cool you know but they do call him
Niko they call Maliki deaky Mike I have
to go to the bathroom on and where does
it happen sometimes well number one in
the bathroom number two number two one
time on the bus the bathrooms on the bus
whoa not the bus are you doing one or
two well you're saying you to go
bathroom are you pissing are you doing I
mean I have an overactive bladder but I
normally hesitate dumb once every day
that's pretty normal
once everyday of course I hope you do
geez but sometimes you don't always have
control over and yeah and I realize what
happened on the bus knew I was going
home one day and doctor before I left
before I got on the bus I eat eat
something so I hadn't eaten all day
what was it it was a chick-fil-a okay it
was some chicken nuggets it was the
first time I had that and then I got
stomach ache and right as the bus came I
got on the bus cuz I knew I was gonna
make the bathroom so I figure I can hold
it but that day the bus had a long ride
down took place it didn't normally go to
and then my thumb I just I couldn't hold
it in and I just went right there where
an accident in on the bus this night
this isn't come on guys this is not true
this is a real person
he went boo-boo it is normally I could
hold it but I did my stomach we just
gave yeah normally he's good about that
yeah yeah so he went to bathroom on the
bus and they had to get off the bus and
get his car and drive home and he had
get Dookie yeah he usually makes it home
to the toilet so true story ready for
this
true story is it Nico with the K or si
si si
true story someone living in Manhattan
and I was leaving my building and a guy
is running down the street and I said to
my daughter what what that what did
something happen like was the guy had
crapped all over the sidewalk was in
eeek
well now he's running because he's
trying to get home and he couldn't make
it and it was just you know just going
everywhere you're running with me how
are you I'm 20 still making doo-doo in
your pants yes is that normal for 20
years old to almost make you to the
toilet sometimes but sometimes I really
his face I can't tell he's being serious
a joke no no he left here and I got on
the bus and then just couldn't hold it
the day dude I know it's because the day
we the reason we found out is because he
didn't come on the air with it he told
one of his co-workers and his co-workers
read it him out yeah I need to see a GI
doctor gastroenterologist for sure I
think was that just a guy in a van what
are the doctors say wait the dark I
hadn't gone for that I've gone for for
bladder issues I haven't overactive
that's different yesterday I haven't G
I'm saying GI which is Gaston not GU GU
is like a urologist okay is it weird
that he has trouble with everything
coming out of both ends
yeah well it's a it's that you can't
control your urgency that's what my
concern is that you're you know
typically your muscle tone prevents I
mean listen all of us sometimes like
geez I can't hold it any freaking longer
sure but I've had that happening while I
was kissing a girl can't hold it anymore
but the kissing was so good kissing yep
and then you made a little why not
honestly Jim I think the deeper we get
into this story we'll find out it was
more of a choice right there on the
president right the second don't waste
it on the bed so now Nico you have you
ever made a wheelie in your pants no
okay yeah no you you need to see a GI
doctor just to make sure that you know
you don't have there a few things that
could be not good what could be
happening that might make him make a
duty well yeah cuz I could clean it up
duty yeah kids now issues coming in in
the morning because I would eat before I
came in and then once I got to the bus
whoa Jeff for breakfast
eggs wide whatever I'd have I'd have a
stomachache Celyn one time it almost
happened again and I'd but it didn't I
made it here so I realized if I stopped
eating I'd be able to go before I got on
the bus but you got a personal make sure
you don't have an allergy or something
cuz allergens can do that right large it
to bathroom is that normal to think like
oh if I stop eating I won't [ __ ] myself
anymore but you know there is IBD
inflammatory bowel disease you know I
mean that sounds really hot bad and sear
it is kind of but you know you got to
checked it up make sure you're young
that you don't have it but is it is it
your parents don't they ask you if you
need the toilet before you leave the
house no yeah they really should I told
you to go before we left
yeah type of thing are you nervous about
this no oh
what happened anymore but I just doesn't
happen to any less either I mean anyone
you could have had a cute food poisoning
also by the way okay you know I mean I
don't think so well but it hasn't
happened since so it's something he said
yes stomach aches every morning on the
bus right I would eat but I stopped
eating a month ago and before I came
here and then I was able to go before I
left the house so then if I had to go
again it'd be after people people a lot
of most people can't eat in the morning
though right yeah like as a doctor have
you found that most people can eat in
the morning like when someone says
breakfast is the most important meal of
the day you shouldn't think nah but I'll
[ __ ] my pants right you got any health
insurance together your parents and my
parents yeah yeah go to see a GI that's
my advice
yeah okay I mean jeez that's pretty you
rolled all in a bus with crapping your
pants sorry I mean I just feel fit it's
just kind of like I feel next 20 20
minutes away from home you just all you
hold it sometimes in life you just gotta
chalk it up as an L yeah hold this out
me could ya that's true you just get the
answer yeah